the prime minister's hero watching over
his successors
a national symbol of courage in wartime
which boris johnson wants to emulate
but also proof you can change prime
minister in conflict
did you lie to parliament prime minister
back on the agenda after boris johnson
became the first inhabitant of number 10
to be fined for law breaking
i take this opportunity
on the first available sitting day
to repeat my wholehearted apology to the
house
but after the apology came the excuses
it did not occur to me then
or subsequently
that a gathering in the cabinet room
just before a vital meeting on covid
strategy could amount
to a breach of the rules
not knowing key to his defense he didn't
mislead parliament
also key is what's going on in ukraine
i feel an even greater sense of
obligation
to deliver
on the priorities of the british people
and to respond in the best traditions of
our country
to putin's barbaric onslaught against
ukraine
the labour leader having none of it as
the latest merely mouthed apology
stumbles out of one side of his mouth
a new set of deflections and distortions
pour from the other
but the damage is already done
the public have made up their mind
they don't believe a word the prime
minister says
they know what he is
most tories asking supportive questions
could i ask the prime minister did you
deliberately mislead the house at the
dispatch box
no mr speaker
but one former chief whip and leadership
contender demand boris johnson quits now
i regret to say
that we have a prime minister who broke
the laws that he told the country they
had to follow
hasn't been straightforward about it and
is now going to ask the men and the
decent men and women on this these
benches to defend what i think is
indefensible
i'm very sorry to have to say this but i
no longer think he is worthy of the
great office that he holds
do you think boris johnson lied to
parliament i i don't think he's been
straight with parliament no and i said
that in my um letter to sergey and brady
i think it's difficult to draw any other
conclusion a humble apology but that's
not enough to shut this issue down
labour calling a vote on thursday over
whether the prime minister lied to
parliament your position want to keep
this issue in the spotlight all the way
to the local elections because it's only
after that and the top official sue gray
has done her report that tories will
really turn their mind to whether they
want to keep boris johnson as their
prime minister
who to keep in the corridors of power
and who to put on parliament's back
benches that's the question for mps but
winston churchill believed you never
give in you never yield to force can
boris johnson emulate this
sam coates sky news westminster